all right this is almost beyond belief
there is video of a meeting at which the
Trump riots were planned
you I mean lordy there are tapes these
are not exactly criminal Geniuses that's
for sure look at this political
reporting the doj has announced a film
crew
was present at the January 5th meeting
between leaders of The Proud boys and
The Oath Keepers the details provide new
evidence of the encounter between the
two groups whose leaders played a key
role in the breach of the capital the
following day
um they're not sending their best and
brighters brightest prosecutors say a
documentary film crew was present
when proud boys leader Enrique tario and
Oath Keepers leader Stuart Rhodes met
for 30 minutes in an underground parking
garage on January 5th now remember
they've both since been arrested and
charged the details revealed in a
justice department Court filing on
Monday provide new evidence of the
encounter between the two groups whose
leaders played a key role in the breach
of the capital the following day quote
while in the parking garage tario told
another individual he had cleared all of
the messages on his phone before he was
arrested prosecutors wrote in a filing
urging a federal Magistrate Judge to
detain tario pending trial tario further
stated no one would be able to get into
his phone because there were quote two
steps to get into it sounds like
two-step authentication
prosecutors say after tario left DC that
night part of a court ordered that he
stay away from the city while facing
charges related to his conduct during a
December 2020 rally he traveled to
Baltimore
that evening tario used the phones of
Associates to make a number of calls and
to log back into his encrypted messaging
accounts after regaining access to his
accounts tario assured his men his phone
had not been compromised Reuters first
reported on the existence of that
meeting and the FBI's interest in it
last month new details suggest Terio
played a more direct role than
previously understood
he's been charged Stewart Rhodes has
been charged Etc uh Reuters report ex
proud boys chairman tario ordered
detained pending trial in capital Riot
case this is also from yesterday
a U.S Magistrate Judge in Miami Tuesday
ordered tario the proud boys chairman
former to be detained while he awaits
trial on charges stemming from the riots
so that is what we call pre-trial
detention now I've spoken out before
about the problems with pre-trial
detention in the United States it's
often applied unfairly it's often
applied
um uh in practice it ends up affecting
those who don't have money for private
lawyers we've been talking about this
for a very very long time these right
Wingers only now care about pre-trial
detention I've been talking about it 10
years on the show
they didn't care they didn't think there
was any problem now they think there is
but
there are videos of the meeting between
tario and Rhodes the people in the
videos have been running around for a
year and many of them probably thought
they were in the clear
but it appears as though what the feds
are and have been doing is following it
all up the food chain it's now hit
Stewart Rhodes it has hit Enrique tario
who knows the full scope of what's in in
these videos but there is a very good
chance that there are still very very
serious charges coming for additional
people
um and I mean consider
you know when this all happened back in
January of 2021
there was maybe the idea among some that
this was all going to be figured out
quickly some people might be charged and
some might end up going to jail prison
Etc uh but we are now 14 months in and
the charges are still coming and not
even everybody who's going to be charged
has been charged so the upside is we're
now at hundreds it might get to
thousands of people who suffer some
consequences for their role in the riot
that would be a very good thing on the
other hand
I am still completely not optimistic
that really the big insiders because
remember the real reason that this even
got going was the false belief that the
election had been stolen from job from
Donald Trump by Joe Biden who
promulgated that it was a bunch of
Republicans and Donald Trump and Mark
Meadows and so on and so forth are they
going to be held accountable no I still
don't think that the vast majority of
them will be that's a problem but
if people committed crimes they should
be charged and they had should have the
book thrown at them and that does appear
to be what's happening video video of
the meeting unbelievable
we have a situation right now where many
companies want and need to hire people
quickly but it is difficult to find the
right candidates and workable is going
to help workable accelerates every step
of your hiring process workable helps
you cast the widest net possible by
posting your jobs to over 200 of the top
job boards with just one click it helps
you evaluate and hire quickly with
modern tools like video interviews and
e-signatures you can automate some of
those repetitive tasks like scheduling
interviews whether you're hiring for
your coffee shop or your engineering
team workable is exactly what you need
to hire the right people fast start
hiring today with a risk-free 15-day
trial if you hire during the trial which
many do it will cost you nothing just go
to workable.com
podcasts to start hiring the link is
down below